kind of hanger
and then there's the kinan agaris
where you to keep slowing him down
[Music]
this one is to make Power him up
the problem is if you don't get the
shade of the hand direction is
[Music]
you don't know who is leading to
you
so you're not in the harm when you've
got money
so it's very important you get the first
stage is correct
[Music]
the first part is
[Applause]
spirit
[Music]
so you know I power him up from this
powerful Bender he says
[Music]
it cannot work if you don't know what to
do with your hands and then yourself
what did you say his name is
so the timing
is important
if you start like this
but as you enter you start doing this
was before that were imaginative just
watched one he won't move
my hands over here
[Music]
about here at this step the direction
the hand is going to stay where it is
so this is where you have to change the
hand shape
[Music]
from here to here
you can get that timing right then
you'll it'll work
[Music]
this is too late now
this is
[Music]
okay I hope the other teachers will
change some weapons
[Music]
that's just a very short version of this
moment
so the place to change direction
[Music]